janvier m'a toujours l'invité de ce set
8 du 27 février ce sont les trente ans
bientôt de votre troupe nous allons en
parler dans ce sera dans quelques mois
en 2014 auparavant un micro-trottoir
black blanc beur pour vous cela signifie
quoi c'est la question que nous sommes
prêts à vous aider à quel point saint
quentinois
une population donnée voilà les jeunes
aujourd'hui moins jeunes maintenant les
algériens moi je trouve ça bien la
mixité actuelle france 98 champion du
monde un black blanc beur
des individus dans un langage courant un
film je crois mais je sais que je sais
pas du tout et ce aux racismes
mitterrand des années 80 puisque c'était
un grand slogan des années 80 couleur de
peau
des petits biscuits aussi ça me fait
penser à un ajustement au monde
d'aujourd'hui où maintenant en france il
ya beaucoup plus de mixité de mélange et
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
la mixité le mélange black blanc beur en
fait cette expression on en a beaucoup
parlé en 98 au moment de la coupe du
monde de football que la france s'était
imposée c'était l'apogée de cette mixité
justement vous relaver créé avant parce
que vous avez déposé le nom black blanc
beur mais je suis aux anges parce que on
a été dépassés
le but c'était vraiment de proposer un
symbole effectivement il y avait
l'arrière-plan du drapeau avec les mêmes
couleurs il y avait aussi quelque chose
qui signifiait à cette époque là quelque
chose après le mouvement des beurs donc
une questionnement d'identité par
rapport à certains de gens qui à tort ou
à raison se vivait comme des minorités
mais bon voilà et et je suis vraiment
ravi parce que c'est à dire sur la
mesure du temps cette idée de mixité
justement ça reste encore bas elle s'est
pas perdu mais elle a été assimilé un
moment au travail de notre compagnie
dans un certain milieu celui touché par
spectacle vivant ou par certains médias
ensuite plus largement mondialement par
la coupe du monde il ya un moment où
elle rejoint ce qu'on entend sur le dans
le micro trottoir c'est à dire l'idée
quand même d'une sorte de vivre ensemble
voilà depuis il ya aussi beaucoup
d'asiatiques donc faut pas rester
attachés à un aspect ou un autre mais
retenir l'idée de ma conjointe inventé
ce mot là j'ai pensé à deux choses 1
trouver quelque chose qui sonne bien
donc j'ai d'abord réfléchi par le son la
baisse à sannois lee thompson et revenir
un sens et c'est vrai que cette promesse
de de gaulle aux algériens aux
sénégalais et aux maliens enfin à tous
ceux qui a abandonné partait aussi pour
revenir avec une citoyenneté française
pleine et entière évidemment sous
jacente et il ya une cohérence je crois
dans ma démarche et dans tout le travail
que j'ai fait avec ça l'idée qu' on
pourrait véritablement arrivé à une
société apaisée en france qui serait
alors complètement apte à être
comment dirais-je amener une
universalité plus que européenne et une
capacité de coopération à ce moment là
qui serait absolument fabuleuse et qui
est nécessaire avec l'afrique notamment
vous parler des origines de la fondation
de black blanc beur est juste morelia
domicile nous a rejoint bon sens aurélia
comment est née cette compagnie est bien
donc janvier maddin effet vous avez créé
en
1984 donc bientôt 30 ans c'est aussi la
raison de votre venue ce soir on va
fêter cet anniversaire l'année prochaine
donc pour rappel à l'époque vous étiez
donc sportif vous étiez éducateur social
c'est vrai que le contexte politique est
un petit peu tendu ces années-là social
sociaux socialement on va dire sociaux
culturellement et donc vous avez eu
l'idée finalement de donner à ces jeunes
l'opportunité de s'exprimer alors je
vais reprendre des termes qui sont de
vous à travers une dense de la rue pour
la rue donc pour ça sur la base d'un
concours vous avez mis en place vous
avez auditionné des centaines de jeunes
de la ville nouvelle 600 jeunes qui se
sont présentés exactement pour au final
constitué donc cette compagnie qui a
donné une première présentation donc en
septembre
c'est sa 84e alors un lieu un peu pas
commun du tout puisqu'il s'agissait du
parking d'un des parkings de la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines public très
urbain exactement et alors vous avez
intitulé ce spectacle j'en ai tout à
donc déjà ça a laissé entendre
quand même
qu'on allait s'emparer des choses on
était plus dans la bof génération alors
du coup moi j'ai envie de vous demander
finalement si on se replace dans le
contexte de l'époque est ce que quelque
part on peut penser vous avez mis en
place et créer une forme de
bouleversements un peu du paysage
culturel français
alors j'ai rectifié une chose ou deux je
vais répondre comment cette question
d'abord c'est pas vraiment enfin une la
première singularité c'est que c'est pas
qu'un travail social et d un travail
d'éducateur quand on dit socioculturel
aujourd'hui on emploie qu'un mot mais en
vérité c'était véritablement une notion
qui était l'aboutissement de toute une
pensée d'éducation populaire qui a lié à
la fois la capacité le principe de
l'utilité sociale de l'émancipation à
produire de l'autonomie à produire et en
même temps la capacité à se construire
une pensée à se construire un
référentiel à se construire soi-même à
s'émanciper au lendemain de la deuxième
guerre mondiale l'éducation populaire a
volé en plusieurs morceaux culture art
d'un côté sport par ici santé par là et
puis j'irai toute la tradition culture
et travail qui s'est retrouvé adossé à
la vie syndicale
quelque part dans le projet black blanc
beur l'idée c'était de re c'était la
synthèse de tout un travail d' approche
globale que nous avions fait d'abord
pour la mise en oeuvre de pour la
construction de la ville nouvelle car en
fait ce projet est la synthèse d'un
ensemble d'expérimentation qui ont été
faites depuis le début depuis 1979 je
vous rappelle que la vie nouvelle elle
est livrée en 76 et qui a abandonné ont
notamment intégrer des opérations du
type info jeunes vous receviez tout à
l'heure des jeunes gens qui étaient en
entreprise nous nous avions organisé
pendant un an la visite d'artistes dans
dix-huit établissements scolaires de
saint quentin avec des artistes et des
journalistes et des chercheurs au
travail c'est un bon gardien et
absolument rien parce que nous avons mis
en évidence mais pas nous seulement nous
on l'a mis en particulier dans la danse
hip hop ou parliez du mouvement hip hop
je précise de la danse hip hop s'il ya
d'autres expressions donc deuxième
précision nous ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a montré que le processus de
construction est aussi important que
l'oeuvre vous un choix que nous avons
fait c'est un paradoxe que nous avons
géré tous ces années que jacques lichine
utah de l'inité notre prédécesseur et m
avaient posé très clairement non je le
cite il disait nous gérons le paradoxe
de l'art pour l'art et de la rue t-il
alors à l'intérieur même de l'ensemble
des identités de la compagnie il ya des
artistes qui sont qui se pose pas des
questions du social l'exigence
artistique a été posée dès le départ et
puis il ya aussi un contexte une
recherche de sens l'envi de fabriquer un
répertoire de faire mémoire j'avais dit
à l'époque
anticiper sur la mémoire d'avenir d'une
ville neuve d'une ville nouvelle et
pourquoi pas anticipé avec une mémoire
métis et vous nous direz c'est justement
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir réussi ce
travail et comment vous vous projetez un
petit peu sur l'avenir on aura
l'occasion de revenir sur toute cette
histoire bien sûr au cours des prochains
mois pour cet anniversaire je voudrais
juste qu'on regarde un extrait est d'un
teaser c'est un court métrage qui a été
réalisé en prévision éventuellement d'un
plus long métrage j'espère tracé est
l'histoire de black blanc beur voilà
pour ces quelques images réalisées par
guillaume va t'en merci
non
à
il est
tu as cru
utilisons les derniers vers l'avant les
filles de l'impasse comme il ya gros si
vous réservez votre problème de fatigue
et mon problème de dynamique soit
quand j'ai créé ma glandeurs
j'allège et j'ai étudié l'histoire et
l'anthropologie
à tolbiac et puis après à la sorbonne
donc évidemment on encore dans une danse
qui vient
qui vient d'amérique avec une insigne
régime qui viennent
voilà pour cet extrait du court métrage
en guise de teaser qui a été réalisé ça
fait une dizaine de minutes en tout et
ça permet éventuellement de poser les
bases d'un long métrage on espère que
vous pourrez le réaliser je dis tout
simplement on espère parce que la
situation aujourd'hui pour black blanc
beur est un petit peu compliqué sur le
plan économique la celle ci à bouquin
chose de l'absolu mansarde aux très
nombreuses compagnies en 2010 un
engagement de l'état n'a pas été honorée
quand je dis pas honoré c'est à dire que
c'était une convention l'année avaient
été engagées les projets avaient été
engagées et le les montants n'ont pas
été perçues au titre d'un changement
d'affectation de ces fonds donc je
prends faire de procès là dessus parce
que je concrétise sur le budget qui vous
manquera pas 30 ans et roman on n'a pas
besoin d'un musée la diffusion on n'a
pas de plus développer la diffusion sur
2013 et on
on tourne moins cette année donc moins
de rentrées d'argent moins de rentrées
d'argent donc on est dans des
difficultés à se projeter alors entre 30
et 60 et 30 et 100 mille euros à peu
près pour relancer la machine est
absolument mais bon c'est à la fois
c'est pas grand chose il suffirait qu'on
vende une dizaine de spectacles pour que
les choses s'équilibrent donc il ya
quand même des inquiétudes c'est des
inquiétudes qui sont partagées par
l'ensemble du milieu d'ailleurs je vous
ai fait parvenir j'espère vous irez sur
le site de téléphiles un argumentaire
pour expliquer que c'est pas les annexes
8 et 10 des intermittents du spectacle
qui font un déficit à l'unedic s'est
expliquée de manière extrêmement claire
je veux bien revenir aussi sur cette
question reviendra en parler bah oui
parce que il ya un moment où est ce que
l'artiste c'est un superflu il ya un
moment où la question du sens elle est
fondamentale et il suffit pas de mettre
d'entasser des richesses consommables
les unes à côté des autres pour être
riche moi la caisse la question que j'ai
souvent posée aux élus c est ce qu une
femme qui allaite son enfant produit de
la richesse ou pas et vous avez le
sentiment d'être entendus ou pas juste
pour conclure mais j'ai senti quelque
chose à ranger sentiment qu'à chaque
fois qu'on amène les élus sur le terrain
de leur propre sensibilité
on rend
trouve l'homme et c'est dans ces
conditions que les choses peuvent
évoluer et on espère qu'elles évoluent
positivement pour blague voix et vous
reviendrez hier sur ce plateau beaucoup
bon pour revenir sur l'ensemble du
travail que vous avez menées depuis plus
de 30 ans mercy gens que j'aimais aussi
en dehors aurélie avoue rester sur le
plateau bien sûr puisque nous allons
continuer cette chronique culture du
mercredi avec vous tout d'abord ce sujet
consacré à la réouverture du casot arrêt
à la maison des familles de la famille à
saint cyr l'école nous en parlions déjà
hier sur ce plateau l'inauguration ayant
eu lieu hier matin voici le reportage
complet de johanna boubekeur à présent
le ruban est coupé
la maison de la famille est là casoar
réouvre à saint cyr l'école oui c'est
pratique puisque tout est au même
endroit donc ça évite d'aller à droite à
gauche pour quelqu'un qui habite la
ville ça peut effectivement être un plus
pour les démarches surtout les
on a des mines ou les personnes âgées on
a des démarches des fois à faire c'est
bien utile après près de deux ans de
travaux et 2,4 millions d'euros investi
les locaux sont neufs et entièrement
réaménagé la maison de la famille
recoupe les services dédiés à la famille
planning familial service logement ccas
et périscolaire le nouveau bâtiment
permet un accès plus simple à des aides
comme yvelines médiation des assistantes
sociales et la croix rouge pour
l'alphabétisation un seul guichet un
seul endroit vous avez par exemple une
personne en difficulté
qui vient faire une demande par exemple
de logements mais là aussi peut-être un
problème est qu'une sm donc on peut en
frappant à la porte d'à côté là tout de
suite d'une assistante sociale plutôt
que de dire aux gens il faudrait que
vous prenez rendez vous voilà on va vous
donner l'adresse là tout peut être fait
dans une seule visite la case war quant
à elle est située dans les sous-sols du
bâtiment de la maison de la famille
c'est un espace dédié à la culture avec
des locaux entièrement réaménagé la
casoar dispose d'une salle de spectacle
d'un studio d'enregistrement et d'une
salle de répétition les locaux sont
accessibles à tous sur simple
inscription